yeah I mean back in the day when I'd be
[ __ ] so gnarly yeah like you never
did cocaine nope never did it once yeah
cause I I remember uh like I would be
like not staying actually would you
travel with cocaine to other countries
I like dead
these guys
definitely kept me off of cocaine
because these guys convinced me
because we would be out and then it
would just be Stevo like
I'm gonna start a t-shirt gummy I'm
having cargo look and I'm like dude
that's all these dudes do is party all
night they get the guy who [ __ ] got
them the drugs now is their new best
friend and all these dudes do all night
is just tell each other the next venture
they're gonna do it's the worst and I
would I'd want to kill all of them
because I'm like dude we're on tour we
gotta do [ __ ] and we gotta film tomorrow
and you're just seeing me around Hawaii
yapping about blood blood and I'm like
I'm gonna kill you and I'm like I'll
never do that
and I've had piles in front of me I've
had it put in my hands like at parties
like here you go and I'm like oh [ __ ]
this yeah that that's good did you ever
smoke a cigarette yeah all right okay
yeah I've smoked weed too has ever done
e never done e
never done mushrooms mushrooms is like a
hot thing right now where everybody's
doing mushrooms
[Laughter]
you never gave them to me me and my
buddies just did a couple and I didn't
like it it was that weird like
I'm like oh no don't want to be there
yeah yeah I think that clip was awesome
but not as awesome as my new book a hard
kick in the nuts what I've learned from
a lifetime of terrible decisions my
first books Five star rated on Amazon
and I have no doubt this one will be too
so get the autograph copy right now at
stevo.com
yeah dude